et bien dans le cadre d'autres magazine
littéraire hebdomadaire j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir aujourd'hui un
personnalités de choix un écrivain que
tout le monde connaît puisqu'il s'agit
d'un des phares de la plume française
est du stylo bille et sénégalais j'ai
noté max palau
eh bien le match palau on ne vous
présente plus et c'est regrettable
chacun a encore en mémoire vos plus
récents succès citons pour mémoire le
soleil se lève un long de la nuit de
tongres qu'une fois par jour
cela s'appelle le crépuscule également
tout dernièrement je crois un quart
d'heure avant midi moins le quart
oui dont le sous titre est 11h30 vous
venez de publier récemment aux éditions
grassouillette volumineuse
correspondance de 350 et 4000 pages dont
voici le premier tome et qui courent
donc la période 1936 1988-89 en 1983
fava 3 oui puisque très vite alors je
dois dire qu'à la lecture de cet ouvrage
assez passionnant vous vous révélez à
témoin privilégié de l'histoire et je
voudrais d'ailleurs que vous ne lisiez à
ce propos une très très belle lettre que
vous avez décrite je crois le 8 mai 1945
vous voulez la lire pour les
téléspectateurs oui alors je m'en
souviens très bien ce jour-là j'écrivais
un monsieur tout ya monsieur douillard
c'est mon plombier ça donc votre
plombier s'appelle giulia
c'est cela mon plombier s'appelle
touyarou tuya c'est un nom qu'on trouve
dans le centre de la france il ya
beaucoup de tuya je vous la lie voulez
vous le dis sans ambages sans jambes
cher monsieur touya la fuite que vous
avez réparé dans mon lavabo serre
produites et provoquent de graves
désagréments à mon voisin du dessous je
vous serais reconnaissant d'avoir
l'amabilité de bien vouloir la réparer
cordialement vôtre
palau
alors cette lettre est effectivement
très importante car finalement on y
trouve déjà été les principaux thèmes de
23 ans déjà et le thème de la fuite et
fuite en avant suite en arrière c'est le
côté aussi oui
qui symbolise d'ailleurs le rejet total
de la société est également le thème de
l'eau de l'eau qui coule qui symbolise
dit dans l'éclosion de la vie mais
toujours stoppé par un obstacle qui est
le lavabo bouché
c'est pourquoi mais ce ballon je vous
pose la question le lavabo bouché
finalement cette fois c'est le symbole
des contraintes de la société oui c'est
surtout qu'on peut plus laver nom alors
je m'en veux à votre style est si
particulier que je qualifierais disons
de 200 me dépouiller même sec également
extrêmement florissant verdoyant et j'en
aurais pour prendre cette apostrophe
dithyrambique au début de cette lettre
ce cher monsieur touya nom max pas loge
je vous pose la question pourquoi ce
cher monsieur
mais parce que l'époque déjà monsieur
tugar me prenait beaucoup d'argent un
rouge mais également qu'a très bien les
traits vocabulaire par exemple le
signifiant la wagon que vous utilisez
dans son sens le plus éclaté oui parce
que le trio avait pété d'un coup et
également lorsque très attention c'est
cette dualité contenant contenu que l'on
retrouve évidemment à temps plus tard
naît alors supprimés sous la forme d'un
conflit entre le roi et de sa très nette
dans cette très très belles lettres que
je crois vous incliner le 13 mai 1958 si
vous voulez bien la lyre ou
téléspectateurs oui alors je remplissais
un formulaire pour mon dossier maladie
de sécurité sociale
je vous le lit sans ambages sens en date
alors il y avait des des cases à remplir
non alors j'ai mis pas l'eau je
m'appelle pas nos prénoms max puisque je
me prénomme max est alors finalement
c'est là que se dévoile finalement toute
la dialectique assez subtil de votre
pensée
parce que finalement à la question donc
s'agit-il d'un accident vous mettez non
mais à la question suivante causé par un
tiers
vous mettez oui
alors je vous pose la question
finalement max malo pourquoi ce oui
parce que c'était la grossesse de ma
femme donc contradictions apparentes
dans l'oeuvre de max gallo et pour
reprendre disons la citation d'albert
tranchons cocuage de la pensée même
finalement qui révèle finalement une
très profonde
disons vision du monde extrêmement
cohérente finalement oui puis toute
façon on a été remboursée donc oui alors
gens reviendront finalement au rejet de
la société je crois que ça vous a pris
très tôt dans votre visa oui c'est ici
si vous me le permettez une lettre que
j'écrivais lorsque j'étais en vacances à
saint menoux en plein en colonie de
vacances
un âge de 6 ans et j'écrivais sa matata
oui je vous le dis sans ambages on
emballe
cher tata je vais bien je mange bien
mais je joue ne veut pas que je joue au
ballon prisonnier avec lui il me tire
les cheveux et il me fait toujours dit
niche bombay c max ou non c'est cela
donc vous ne signez pas encore à ce
moment là pas long non je signe de mon
prénom devrais je dire de mon surnom car
comme de chacun c'est max ou mais est le
diminutif de max finalement toujours
conflit avec la société la société que
faire celui fait par le carnage de jojo
jojo c'est la société
josé la société qui vous tirent les
cheveux pour l'avenir et cheveux
finalement que l'on retrouve dans le
baba bon donc finalement la boucle est
bouclée monsieur ce sont les cheveux
qu'il avait bougé n'est pas bon alors on
s'est aperçu en fait que c'était le
bouchon du tube de dentifrice avec de la
ouate qui était dans le tuyau est
toujours votre style si judicieusement
disant bipolaire simplicité extrême et
complicité complexité pas en extrême qui
met loger oui plus les fautes
d'orthographes qu'ils sont
là pour authentifier la justesse de mes
pensées et la pertinence de mes propos
pertinence d'ailleurs que l'on
retrouvera plus tard dans cette très
belle lettre d'amour que vous écrivez à
l'occasion des grands événements de mai
1968 si vous voulez bien la lyre
téléspectateurs alors je voudrais
signaler que c'est la seule lettre
d'amour que j'ai jamais écrite
je vais vous la lire sans ambages samba
chère madame
veuillez trouver ci joint la photo
couleur dans l'attenté d'une prompte
réponse je vous prie de bien vouloir
agréer l'expression de mes sentiments
distingués
palau c'est très très émouvant c'est de
fougue sexuelle contenu cependant je
dirais plutôt retenu car j'ai commencé
ma carrière sexuelle et mes premiers
ébats affectif à l'âge de 60 ans
il ya max palau merci c'est sur ce
message d'espoir
nous vous laissons car je crois que vous
avez actuellement du pas sur la plage
vous travaillez à un nouvel ouvrage wii
dont la conception est très délicate car
elle consiste en une compilation de
toutes mes factures d'eau et de gaz
depuis bientôt 30 ans mais sans doute
encore un immense un immense cri de
révolte un titre max gallo ya de l'eau
dans le gaz